Well,
again,
I see that it's a consequence of
continual adjective,
agitation by I would say a minority of
the left,
the radical left in particular,
and those are people who aren't Marxist
Slash Neo Marxist in their fundamental
ideological orientation and have joined
that in an unholy union with the worst
of French postmodernism and and they,
they push it forward ideological
certainty and the thing that,
the thing that's really distressing
about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people,
let's say,
much as I hate to engage in that
particular form of dialogue under the
current conditions,
it's pretty obvious that it's freedom of
speech is freedom.
That's particularly important for people
who don't have anything else,
right?
It's,
if you're supporting freedom of speech,
you're not supporting the status quo.
I mean,
just think about,
let's,
let's use the logic of the radical
leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at
the top have the upper hand in
everything,
including access to communication.
These people are not your friends.
No,
that's mark my words.
Now it's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates.
Right?
That's awesome.
I'll tell you again to use it in Kuwait,
what would you call it in Kuwait?
Sensation is the best formulation of
their argument.
And there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you.
So keep that in mind.
It's not a music,
there's nothing to it.
There's nothing for it.
I think that's also quite appalling is
that there is no evidence whatsoever
that the people who are conducting these
protests know what it is that they're
protesting against in a way was in.
Alright,
alright.
I was in the midst of a discussion and
attempting to make the case that it's
freedom of speech.
That's.
That is what people who have nothing
still have.
Right?
So if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society,
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication.
Everyone knows that it's the people at
the bottom who have the right to say
what they think,
however badly they say it.
It enables them to get a toe hold into
the system and to and to make their
suffering known.
That's what freedom of speech is for and
so like what's the protest against that,
and I'll tell you,
you know that the rowdy called Neo
Marxist types.
They speak the language of power and
that's what they're speaking right now,
and if you want to live in a world where
everyone speaks the language of power,
then just let them do what they're doing
and see what happens.
I wouldn't recommend it.
It's not a pretty rote and you're all in
a position.
You're on a situation in your life now
where you have to make decisions about
this sorts of things.
Like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be.